hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game also from round one of the
knockouts uh of the uh ancient used
rapid tournament it's already versus
wesley so and this game is so
complicated that you will want to watch
it twice i i'm not even kidding uh so
let's check it out and uh
you decide for yourselves uh if it if
it's necessary alerissa with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 uh c4 e6 knight to c3 and the bishop
to b4 now we go for the nimso indian
defense uh f3 the mall variation and now
c5 striking in the center uh we have d5
advancing the d-pawn and now black plays
b5 and this is made possible uh since
white uh will not be able to
keep an eye on his central pawn if he
captures on b5 so no point in doing that
if pawn captures on b5 we're gonna play
e captures our knight captures and we're
gonna have a really really great
position with black here so instead
white just grabs the center we have e4
and now we have castles again capturing
on b5 doesn't really give anything if
for example characters we're just going
to play captures captures rookie check
and black is already better bishop is
coming to b7 we're going to attack the
d5 pawn even further and black will
always be better here
so instead we have e5 by ferugia
knight to e8 and now f4 so really
grabbing that uh central space uh e
captures on the 5c captures on d5 and d6
now now it's uh not a problem as white
does not have the opportunity to advance
the pawn to e6 and his king is still in
the center of the board so it definitely
makes sense to open up the uh the center
we have knight to f3
c for now uh and as the pawn has now
been advanced we're gonna undermine the
pawn chain with a5 so attacking that b5
pawn we have knights to d7 uh and now
bishop to e2 so now white is finally
ready to castle but of course wesley
will not allow this queen to b6 prevents
white from castling
bishop to d2 and now knight to c7 uh we
have knight captures and b5 uh knight
captures on d5 and now bishop captures
and b4 we have knight captures on b4 and
now finally knight captures and d6 so
this has all been played before even
though the position is a complete mess
bishop to a6 black finally connects his
rooks and now uh in the game uh that
the the position has been reached knight
captures and c4 was played but here we
have queen to d2 by faruja and now it is
as of move 17 that we have a completely
new game uh someone mentioned in the
comments on the previous video that
during the morphe saga games usually
lasted for 17 moves and nowadays in
modern chess
it is only as of move 17 that we have a
completely new game but chess uh you
know progressed a lot in in the past 150
years uh so let's see how wesley
continues uh against this novelty we
have knight to c5
uh if you go for knight to d3 check it
it looks like something you want to do
but after bishop captures and c captures
uh black really doesn't have all that
much here yes it looks great the white
king is in the center of the board you
have your bishop guarding the past pawn
queen is preventing the king from
castling uh but sometimes in chess it's
not uh as it seems here white would play
b4 and there's no way to take advantage
of the with the white king being in the
center of the board rookie to b8 we're
going to push b5 after the bishop moves
we're going to push a5 and it's just
very good for us queen to c5 and now
rook to c5 as a rook to c1 finally we
get rid of the queen from the c file uh
not from the c file from this diagonal
and once the queen moves we can finally
castle and we're just gonna have a have
a great game uh so instead after this
queen to d2 move wesley continues with
uh sorry whistler continues knight to c5
and now after a5 attacking the queen
queen to b8 and only now that the queen
left this diagonal we have uh castle's
king side uh we have knights to be three
attacking ferocious queen here and queen
to e3
and now uh this is uh this is an
exchange sacrifice but it appears to be
even more than that wesley captures the
rook on a1 but alireza doesn't recapture
he doesn't plays knight to g5 so he's
going for the attack ideas like queen uh
h3 to e4 might be going for for that
checkmating sequence uh wesley has to
get rid of the knight he plays h6 and
now alireza doesn't move the knight he
plays knight to f5 uh and the problem is
uh if you capture the knight is just a
very nice checkmate into 97 check king
wherever doesn't really matter and queen
to h3 is checkmate the knight is
covering g8 and the g6 squares
so here after knight to f5 uh wesley
played queen to c7 with the idea of
playing f6 and the queen will help out
with the defense of the seventh rank but
this game this move loses the game for
wesley but it's such a complicated
variation only one line is winning and
uh
there's simply no way of finding it
already spent almost 10 minutes of a
rapid game trying to calculate all the
way to the end but he couldn't do it and
he avoided it but uh you are comfortable
in your own homes hopefully you know uh
having more more than 10 minutes uh so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find it the only move that wins here for
alireza while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on you know being the
greatest player that ever existed and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's knight captures on h6 of
course we all think of this move but
you can't really just play it against uh
wesley and hope that good things will
happen you have to calculate everything
out so the point is uh the knight has to
be accepted because if you move the king
we're just going to play queen to h3 and
you're getting checkmated either the
knight moves or you capture the knight
and then it's just where a nice queen to
h7 checkmate so g captures on h6 and now
we play queen to g3 again it's not
pleasant for black because if the knight
is captured uh then we capture with the
queen king hit queen f6 check king to h7
and now rook f3 and rook to h3 will
deliver checkmate
but of course after queen to g3 we don't
have to capture we're going to move our
king we're going to play king to h8
so now we continue the attack with queen
to h4 attacking the h6 pawn and now king
to g7 and here uh it's uh
not all that difficult to calculate all
of this out up until this point but now
uh continuing to calculate further in
finding the the only winning sequence
from that position where alireza was
supposed to
supposed to sacrifice the knight
that's something else entirely for a
rapid game
uh here f5 f5 is the move uh and now of
course you can't play f6 to prevent the
pawn from reaching f6 because then
knight to e6 check just wins the queen
so here you don't really have anything
good rook the g8 we have to start
running away with our king now comes f6
check king to f8 and now uh the
brilliancy knight the e6 check uh
attacking the king and the queen uh you
have to capture the knight so f captures
and now queen captures an h6 with check
king
e8 and now f7 check and that's it we win
the game uh
either the queen captures and then we we
we just pick up the queen uh or we go
into this uh king to d7
line then f captures on g8 with check
and not with check by the way promoting
to a queen rook captures on g8 and now
rook to f7 with check now we're gonna
win uh black's queen uh on c7 king to c6
we're gonna capture here
captures with check king has the capture
and now finally queen to h7 check to
pick up the rook here and we will be up
uh of material and of course in a
completely winning game king c6 queen
captures on g8 and that's it so not uh
you know only some 12 moves to consider
plus all of the sub variations uh if
you've done this then truly
congratulations you are you are the
greatest player to have ever existed uh
so after queen to c7 alireza thought
about the position for some 10 moves but
he decided against it he played knights
to e4 he couldn't calculate everything
out and now wesley plays f6 now the
queen will help out with with the
defense of the seventh rank so now uh
any sacrifices uh will not be uh all
that great and that now alireza has to
decide whether to capture the knight or
or not but he uh wants to continue
attacking queen to g3 now the thread is
knight captures here and uh of course
the the pawn is pinned so king the h8
you have to move the king away e
captures on f6 uh now again the knight
doesn't have time to escape because we
simply capture here and win the game so
rook captures on f6 knight captures on
f6 and now
the problem is if you capture with the g
pawn then queen to g6 wins the game
you're attacking this point you're
attacking this pawn and if something
like rook to g8 we're going to capture
on h6 and if queen to h7 now we're going
to capture on f6 and if rook to g7 now
rook f3 and again rook to h3 is our you
know ace in the sleeve
so after knight captures on f6 wesley
plays the absolute best move that is
queen to c5 check and he's going after
the f5 knight so here we have king to h1
uh you could also block with the knight
the queen is guarding uh
the the knight here but after g captures
uh sorry g captures on f6 uh the queen
is now stuck here guarding the knight
and you don't really have a good way of
continuing your attack so after queen to
c5 check we have king to h1 by alireza
and now queen captures an f5 we have
knights to h5 now threatening checkmate
here on g7 and the queen to f7 defending
and now f5 now alireza wants to play f6
and just you know continue attacking
he's not interested in picking up this
knight here
it's not really doing anything so here
wesley tries to reactivate it knight a
to c2 and now f6 we have g5 g6 or g5 has
to be played here if g6 then knight f4
will attack the
upon here so maybe g5 right away and
this is what wesley goes for knight the
g7 by alireza now uh maybe ideas like
queen to h3 are are again possible uh
but now c3 and this is just such an
incredibly resourceful uh move by by
wesley uh attacking the bishop here and
also preparing uh c captures on b2 that
will create a beautiful pass pawn of his
own so here uh we have to capture we
have uh uh well just uh sorry not
pawn captures but bishop captures on a6
uh and now uh pawn captures on b2 if you
capture on a6 now then queen to h3 is a
very very dangerous queen to g6
defending now we're going to play queen
captures on c3
and you don't have all that much uh the
queen cannot move to prevent f uh sorry
you can't really prevent the pushing of
the pawn the queen has to keep an eye on
the knight here uh and the once you move
the king away from this diagonal then we
just play knight to e6 and now we're
gonna continue advancing this spawn not
a lot black can do here you can't stop
because then the knight falls and well
the knight already covers this square
nothing for black to do here so instead
after this bishop captures an a6 wesley
does not recapture wesley plays a c
captures on b2 now he has a very
dangerous pass pawn of his own and now
bishop back to e2 by alireza uh guarding
that h5 square he wants to get the
knight back
sort of into the game because the rook
the f8 is coming and he wants to have uh
sufficient defense of the f6 pawn so
rook to f8 we have knight to h5 and now
knight to d4 further activating this
knight and now queen to c3 offering up
the bishop for the b for knight
uh wesley accepts this there doesn't
appear to be anything better queen
captures on b4 and now we have king the
g8
now the the queen can move the king will
be guarding the rook here on f8 uh and
now alireza feels that uh well this
position is just great for him he has a
beautiful pawn here on f6 and black
really doesn't have all that many
squares so he offers a trade of knights
wesley captures this we have knight
captures h h captures and now queen to
h5 with check king the g1 and now comes
queen to e2 uh sort of defending his
past pawn here
and uh it's now already very dangerous
for both of them uh but a little bit
easier to play for white and alireza has
to find a very uh particular move here
and he does here he plays queen to b3
with check
and this is now a well a winning
position for him but you have to play it
absolutely precisely uh we've rooked to
f7 blocking and now rook to b1 going
after this pawn
so what do you do here rook to d1 is
also very nice uh because uh rook here
is just a terrible threat the king would
have to move and then we're just gonna
capture the the rook here so we would
have to see queen to e8 and now queen
captures on b2 wins the pawn like this
and the defense the f6 pawn so this is
one way to go about it the other way is
uh
how alireza did it rook the b1
and now what do you play here uh here we
have queen to e5 the thing is if you
try something else there's
not much you you can do because uh the
rook is still pinned you can't move the
rook the king doesn't have any good
squares for example you could uh you
could try something like king to f8 to
get out of it but then we deliver queen
to b8 to check and it's just uh you know
a bad there's no squares for the king
you have to block with the queen then we
capture back and again we're defending
our pawn so white will always be winning
here so instead of wesley played queen
to e5 saying that okay now i'm defending
the the pawn and if you move the queen
away from this diagonal then my rook
will be able to capture on f6 when
everything is said and done uh so here
we have queen captures on b2 but now
wesley doesn't go for the line that
saves him for the queen captures rook
captures and rook captures here but
instead he goes for queen captures on a5
now he creates a pass pawn on the queen
side but uh it's a very very
uh well the different from from the line
that's already uh safe uh here we have
queen to d4 by alireza uh and uh this is
a very very unpleasant for wesley but
queen to c2 would have been even more
unpleasant the problem is if you capture
the rook then queen to c for check and
there's no way for the king to escape
king here rook to b7 check king g6 queen
to e4 check and now after the queen
blocks we play queen to e8 to check and
finally after rook to f7 we play queen
to g8 to check and now there is no way
to defend if you move the rook uh well
the queen and rook guarded that square
if you move the king here then the queen
no longer defends the rook we can just
capture and that's it white just wins
but alireza tried queen to d4 here and
now we have queen to c7 by wesley uh
last attempt at defending was something
like queen to f5 but uh you know it's a
rapid chess you can't possibly see
everything queen to c7 was played but
now we have queen to e4 uh now you're
ready to go for that the queen to g6 uh
check so rook captures here and now
comes rook to b7 uh and here again it
looks desperate but uh you you could
still kind of play this but you have to
play it precisely here wesley played
queen captures on b7 he grabbed the rook
on b7 as he thought there's no way out
but queen to c5 check prevents the queen
from reaching the g6 square because
after queen to c5 check king to h2 we're
just gonna play queen to f5 and now
we've prevented queen to g6 and after
queen a8 check for example we can always
block uh this with for example rook to
f8 queen to e7 threatening checkmate
queen to f7 and we you know continue
defending we're even up upon if you know
anyone asks uh but yeah this was another
way for wesley to save the game but he
didn't see it he played queen captures
and b7 he thought okay maybe i'm i can
hold this he knows that this is winning
but you know it's rapid maybe he will be
successful queen captures on b7 rook to
f7 trying to create a fortress here
defending the a7 pawn uh and now queen
to c6 we have king to g7 king to h2 now
it is a wants to shift his king over to
h5 and then uh just win the game so rook
to f8 we have came to h3 rook to f6
uh queen to d7 check rook to f7 queen to
d for check now uh came to g6 and now we
have queen to e4 check and it was in
this position on move 52 that wesley so
resigned in the game and what an
incredible game this was there were
so many so many ways for both of them to
go wrong but uh uh all in all uh wesley
defended uh
great but alireza attacked better uh it
would seem and uh it's so so awesome how
he left uh that night on a1 without ever
capturing it it's just he he
instinctively knew that that night had
nothing to do with this game and that
the
sacrifice was justified so here you
resign because after
you deal with this check of course you
can't play something like this then we
play something like g4 win the rook on
the spot uh if you move the king uh for
example king uh or king to g7 then you
allow the white king to enter the game
and there's no real move that you can
play here you're gonna have to
play a move that you don't want
something like a6 then we go in with
king to h5 and then after rook to f6 it
seems like you're still defending
everything but now we go for queen to d4
we uh
uh force uh black to do something that
he doesn't want to
either push the pawn here which will
make it vulnerable uh or move the king
you can't really do anything else so
you'd have to play king f7 queen d7
check now the king has to move somewhere
and now queen to e7 again we force a
black to make uh a move with the rook
and that's very unpleasant uh if you go
somewhere like rook to b6 then queen to
d8 check picks up the rook and if you
try to save the rook with rook to f7
then queen to e6 and now you can't
defend everything uh you know pawns will
start falling and this is going to be an
easy win for white
so after queen t for czech wesley
resigned and what a brilliant victory
for alireza ferrugia in this uh well
game that could have gone either way uh
but that was really my favorite moment
of the game uh here where all of you
guys found it after queen the c7 this
knife captures an h6 with this unique
set of moves that you know is
you know completely incredible uh but
yeah uh that's the game i hope you guys
uh enjoyed it and that everyone solved
this position uh i would like to thank
david kimura vladilaro mark thompson
annie mccain and emmanuel gevardi for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the chess world uh thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day